Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain a Spanish science-fiction thriller film
called “The Last Days.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
The premise of the movie is set
in a post-apocalyptic society.
After a mysterious disease spreads all across
the world, people become extremely agoraphobic,
meaning that they develop a fear of the outdoors.
The disease takes over so quickly that the people
who are outside when it happens, die instantly.
While the survivors stay wherever they are.
It is currently three months after the
disease took over and a cure has still
not been found. The world has collapsed as
people stopped coming out of their houses.
An office worker named Marc was at work when
the pandemic took over. Ever since then,
he has not been able to return home to his
wife Julia. At the beginning of the movie,
Marc scavenges through his office building
for food. Alongside him, his coworkers are
busy going about their day as they have for
several months now. He tries to use the phone,
but as expected, it doesn’t work. A view of the
city through the window shows us the destruction
caused by the pandemic. Marc looks at the
empty streets while eating a piece of bread.
His colleague asks him to come downstairs because
it is his turn to work. For the past month,
they have been making a tunnel that they can use
to go places since they cannot walk outside.
As Marc hits the wall, he creates a hole in
it and finds out that the other end meets a
subway tunnel. Later, everyone is being given
rationed food supplies. While waiting in line,
Marc sees his former boss Enrique hiding a GPS in
his pocket. When he asks him what the GPS is for,
Enrique dismisses the matter. A flashback reveals
that before the pandemic, Marc was working as a
computer engineer. One day, Enrique calls him into
the office and asks him about a deadline that Marc
had missed earlier. He threatens Marc for possible
termination from the job if he isn’t efficient
enough the next time. Marc works overtime that
night and ignores the calls from his wife Julia.
He returns home late to see Julia has already
had dinner. The couple talks about their plan
to have a baby soon. Marc doesn’t want to rush
the subject when he is having trouble at work
but Julia is impatient. They have had several
arguments about the matter in the past.
At night, Marc cannot fall asleep so he
watches the news about a sixteen years
old teen who commits suicide after staying inside
his house for more than six months. He had severe
agoraphobia but his father didn’t understand or
believe him, leading him to commit suicide.
The following day in office, everyone discusses
the teen’s tragic death. Marc notices that one of
his colleagues, Rovira, is wearing the same
clothes that he did for the last few days.
It is almost as if he hasn’t returned home. At the
time, Marc didn’t understand what Rovira’s problem
was but looking back at it now, he was one of
the first people to get infected by the disease.
In the present, Marc and Enrique are in Enrique’s
office secretly discussing the GPS. Since the
phone’s GPS has stopped working, Marc needs
the device to reach his apartment. Enrique
requests Marc not to tell the others about
the device or else they will probably steal
it in the time of crisis. Marc reveals that he
has stolen supplies formerly owned by Rovira.
Using both of their tools, they can partner up
and help each other reach their destinations.
Enrique also needs help in going to Vila Olímpia,
but he doesn’t specify his reasons. Enrique is
initially dismissive of Marc's idea and declines
to partner with him, but Marc blackmails him into
helping him search for Julia. The two set out into
the subway system, and start their journey. Some
hours later, they reach the subway station which
has now become home to hundreds of people.
All of a sudden, a pickpocket snatches Enrique’s
bag with supplies and runs away. They chase
after him and reach a secluded area with the
pickpocket’s gang members. The thugs make the
two kneel down, wanting to steal all their
supplies. Fortunately for Enrique and Marc,
the power goes out right on time,
and they attack the group of thugs.
In the fight, Enrique kills the leader. Although
worried that Enrique will continue without him,
Marc is relieved to find that he is willing to
continue their partnership. Another flashback
shows us, Marc, getting ready to go to the
office unknown of what is coming. On his way,
he enters his neighbor’s home which is filled
with trash that seems to have accumulated over
the course of months. It is clear that he has also
been infected but has no clue what is going on.
At work, the officials find out that Rovira has
been living in his office for several weeks. They
kick him out of the building as he begs for his
life. People think he is being too dramatic but
as soon as he is taken outdoors, he gets a
seizure and dies. Following that, Marc goes
through his belongings and sees that Rovira has
accumulated food and other supplies. At night,
Marc tells Julia that something is happening
around them that they are not aware of yet.
The incidents bother Marc but he doesn’t know what
he can do about them. Julia hugs him but believes
that he is worrying for no reason. They make love
before going to sleep. Back in the present, Marc
wakes up dreaming of her. He gets worried when he
sees no one around but is relieved when Enrique
approaches him moments later. The two continue
their journey through the subway tunnel. Marc
inquires why Enrique wants to go to Vila Olimpia
but he dismisses the conversation. He also has
been collecting seeds of several fruits throughout
the journey which Marc thinks is weird.
After walking for some miles, they find the
opening to the sewer system. They jump into
the sewer and use the GPS to get to the building
that Marc lived in. To get out of the sewer,
they will have to blow up a gas cylinder and make
a hole through the ground. They miss the first
two tries but are eventually able to create the
explosion. Marc finally gets to his room but sees
that it is occupied by a strange man. At first, he
thinks that the man has abducted his wife but it
turns out that he and his family were working in
the building. When they got infected they couldn’t
return home so they took shelter in his apartment.
On being asked about Julia, they claim that
the apartment was empty when they came in. Enrique
looks around the kitchen and finds that the family
has caught birds for food. He also collects corn
kernels and puts them inside the bag with the
other seeds. Meanwhile, Marc finds a hospital
paper with Julia’s ultrasound report in it.
It is then revealed that she was pregnant when
they last met. We are shown yet another flashback
where Marc and Julia are watching the news about
the disease spreading at an exponential rate. The
condition is now known as “the panic” and several
people have already died because of it.
Julia brings up the topic of having children
and they, yet again, get into an argument.
While walking to work, Marc notices the streets
and the train are emptier than usual. People at
work are also listening to the news where the
“experts” claim the cause of “the panic” is just
mass hysteria. Marc feels guilty for arguing with
Julia but when he calls, her friend Andrea picks
up the phone. Wanting to talk to Julia, he leaves
to go home. However, as soon as he steps outside,
he falls to the ground, panicking. Marc has also
been infected by the disease. He somehow drags
himself inside the building. In the present, it
suddenly starts to rain. Enrique and Marc collect
water with the help of a curtain and a bucket.
Everyone in the apartments does the same as well.
At night, the two collect as many supplies as
they can and leave for their next destination.
Marc wants to go to the mall that Julia used
to work in but Enrique says that they are going
to Vila Olimpia next. Since they have reached
his apartment building, he no longer wants to
accompany Marc. They get into a fistfight which
ends almost immediately after they accidentally
break the flashlight. Enrique then reveals that
he wants to go to the hospital that his father
is in. After finding him, he promises to give
the GPS to Marc, so he accepts the deal.
The two continue the journey and end up in
an abandoned church at the end of the night.
They find a lighter and use it to light a fire,
hoping to have a cozy night. However, their plan
is ruined when they are attacked by a wild bear.
It attacks Enrique and is almost about to maul him
to death but Marc manages to kill it at the right
time. Following that, they cook the bear’s flesh
and devour it. As they eat, they talk about
their lives before the pandemic. It turns out
Enrique’s only family is his father who he loves
dearly. As they get to know more about each other,
they start to bond. The next day, they continue
the journey through the sewers to the hospital.
On their way, they meet another group of survivors
who claim that they have heard the rumors about
the hospital being burned to the ground. Enrique
freaks out and runs to a building’s top. There,
through a glass window, he sees that the hospital
has in fact burned. Since his father was paralyzed
and was on the fifth floor, he loses all hopes of
his survival. With no one to love or look after,
Enrique loses the will to live and tries to
jump off the window but Marc saves him.
Enrique now wants Marc to continue looking
for Julia on his own. He even hands the man
his bag of seeds, saying that his child will need
them in the future. After an emotional goodbye,
they part ways and Marc makes his
way to the mall that Julia worked in.
He reaches the mall without much problem and
finds several dead bodies lying on the ground.
People there seem to have fought their lives off.
He enters the shop that Julia worked in, only
to find its owner dead on the floor. Fortunately
for him, Julia’s friend Andrea has written a note
saying that they are at the supermarket. On
his way there, he meets a group of survivors.
They are reluctant to let him in but they agree
to see if someone named Julia is in their group.
Before they can get back to him a rival group
attacks them. The ensuing fight causes most
of the people from both groups to die. Amidst the
chaos, Marc meets Andrea who tells him that Julia
has gone to the gynecologist after Marc ended the
call that day. They try to run away but Andrea is
killed by falling debris. Following that, a man
attacks Marc and is about to kill him but Enrique
arrives at the right moment and saves him.
But just after, Enrique is stabbed in the chest.
He hides his injury from Marc and offers to join
him to search for Julia. They walk through the
tunnel and end up in an auditorium. Marc runs
to one of the upper floors of the building and
sees Julia in the opposite building through the
window. Julia also notices him and is overjoyed.
Marc quickly runs back to tell Enrique about her
but finds him bleeding to death. Enrique urges him
to go find Julia and live his life happily before
passing away. Now, Julia and Marc are at the
entrance of two opposite buildings. Marc takes the
chance and runs across the street to meet her. His
head gets lighter and his ears start to bleed but
he somehow manages to get to his wife in the end.
The two finally reunite and look at each
other with tears of joy. Some months later,
Julia gives birth to a healthy boy. They
use the seeds that Enrique had given Marc
to create a greenhouse. As their kid grows up,
he takes his first step into the outside world
proving that he is immune to agoraphobia. When
he is a teenager, several other kids his age
come to take him to rebuild civilization. The
movie ends as Marc and Julia watch their son
walk away with his group of friends.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.